he feels safer here than in a shopping
mall gegen kipkorir now prefers the
small neighborhood stores on the
outskirts of Nairobi when the gunman
struck gegen was working as a salesman
at the Westgate Mall he was in the
textiles department when panic broke out
and people started to flee yay GaN hid
behind bales of cloth and stayed there
for hours before he was finally rescued
he has little two-step I'm not saying
I'm I'm just okay I'm just doing some
work infused in amana yeah I simply
because you can still remember there
what up any at twisted security has
tightened in Nairobi since the attack
not just in shopping malls but in office
buildings and hotels across the city but
Kenyans don't seem interested in the
trial they have little faith in the
investigation and it's not clear if all
the attackers are accounted for we don't
know whether they're caught or not cause
there somewhere we either dead or alive
we don't know just like Osama bin Laden
we don't know where you are until what
what is this hatch to believe what do
you what do you take us the truth media
the government yay gan kipkorir doesn't
feel safe despite the increased security
like many of his countrymen he's not
convinced by the investigation and
expects little from the trial